so it's just a really really really big
iPad well it's not that simple yes this
is the iPad pro or the super mega big
iPad as I like to call it but over my
last week of testing I've been asking
myself almost constantly what is it
really is it a laptop is it a sketchbook
is it a mini TV is it an $800 lunch tray
not terrible yes it's really fun to make
fun of the iPad pros ginormous screen
but it's that 12 point 9 inch screen
that makes it one of the most versatile
gadgets ever made and one capable of
real productivity speaking of I got to
get back to work work work work so I get
this girl off the screen get my email on
the Left Safari on the right that's the
best part about having the widescreen I
just wish I could put two of the same
app say to Safari windows side by side
and managing all those open apps not a
problem thanks to the pros incredibly
fast a 9 X processor it even exported a
4k video in iMovie a minute faster than
my MacBook Air for real work though
you'll want the $170 smart keyboard
which is powered by this new connector I
love typing on the bouncy fabric keys
and hitting command tab is a huge time
saver when you want to toggle to other
apps oh and did I mention it's
spill-proof still many times I wished
for something closer to Microsoft
Surface type cover Apple's only props up
to one angle attaching it is confusing
and sometimes it does this but Apple did
beat Microsoft and Sony stylus I think
you mean pencil the $100 Apple pencil
provides the best digital sketching and
writing experience I've ever had on tab
I loved it for brainstorming and taking
notes at meetings it kept up with my
fast and small handwriting - okay
clearly I'm no artist but I did lend it
to an illustrator who was able to draw
this pretty amazing and when you're
finally ready to chill like all their
iPads before it the pro is great for
looking at photos and videos the
high-resolution screen makes it one
killer Netflix machine though a surface
like kickstand would have come in handy
Apple's pro has the real edge on battery
life though I was able to stream eight
hours of Netflix with brightness set at
75 percent the pro is good at other iPad
things too but please don't take selfies
with it and at one point six pounds I
would steer away of reading on it in bed
so the iPad pro is many things but it
won't be the thing for everyone until
it's a better laptop for now it's a
great sketchbook it's a great mini TV
and above all it's a great super mega
big iPad that hints at the future where
a single computing device can do it all
you know just look so big anymore